all right let's jump into this first
throw we got this from timcast.com
homeless man executed in broad daylight
on St Louis sidewalk there's a clip of
uh of what happened just before the
shooting um we're not going to play the
video now I will say the video doesn't
actually show the execution it shows
right up into the point of it you see
the guy slowly loading the weapon he's
like shaking it and then there's someone
narrating behind glass like watching it
happen being like he's hey you just put
a magazine in it's like don't you
realize what he's about to do here's the
crazy thing about this story so
apparently they caught the guy I guess
but the crazy thing is when the dude is
about to load the magazine you know he
has no access to he's not he's unable to
use that weapon at that current moment
nobody wanted to do anything
so we get two things out of this story
for one I want to make sure I point out
stories like this probably happen a lot
in big cities and by a lot I don't mean
like every single day
but frequent enough I've seen stuff in
Chicago that would make your your blood
boil and uh sometimes people just
randomly shoot other people and things
like that this is one of these stories I
think people were shocked by this the
reason the video went viral is not just
that you're seeing this this callous
murder but that no one cares to do
anything anymore Carl Benjamin from the
Lotus Eaters podcast says this is a
social contract you don't have to do
anything so why would you you no longer
have to protect anyone else so I was
thinking about this and just to kick
things off I was thinking about I did
this segment on you know feminism and
stuff the other day
about gender roles and why we have
certain cultural traditions and it's
because we want to survive and sir we
survive better when we're together
that's why a single person out in the
middle of the woods might end up dying
but with 10 or 15 people they can work
together and distribute the the workload
and end up Surviving but now that we
live in this sterile mechanized cyborg
Society no one knows each other and no
one cares and it seems like
I guess the side effect of absolute
luxury of humans being able to drink
sugar I mean just think about crazy look
at this I got I got another Coca-Cola
tonight I don't know why you can
probably tell me talking fast but we
we've extracted sugars and Hyper
concentrated now we just drink it and
that's something that you don't find in
nature for the most part maybe fruit
juices but even that you're not getting
this much we have so much luxury we
literally just don't care about anybody
else
back in the day you're in the middle of
the woods you're like please we got to
work together we're going to die now
it's dude we've got so much food in the
shelves you're actually pissing me off
get away from me and so when stuff like
this happens people just don't care but
I think it's also like people don't feel
a connection to other people in the
public like what connects us anymore
it's not religion it's not our ethnicity
it's not our culture everyone has their
own little cultures everyone has their
own little groups and I think when you
put everybody together in big cities
like this we are living in a very
mistrustful Society um this reminds me
this thing we're talking about reminds
me of I used to spend Summers out in
Montana
and we used to buy some of our produce
and products from this group of people
called the Hutterites they're like the
Amish with a little different things and
what they would do is they would make
their communities and after it got to a
certain size around 100 people they
would start another little colony
because they realized that you cannot
feel a connection to somebody when your
Society gets too big when their colony
gets too big and you're not seeing a
person that's working for you putting
food on your table cleaning your beds
whatever it is you lose that connection
and you lose the I think the the
humanist instinct to you know put
yourself out there for other people and
I think that we're seeing that on a
large scale in society that nobody feels
this connection nobody feels this
obligation to care about one another we
just we just don't need so much of it
and you know it used to be you did the
work you had to do and then other people
would do work that would complement your
life so you know one guy grows the wheat
another guy Cooks it and makes it into
bread and then you you share the guy
with the wheat says okay I'll give this
to you and says okay I'll make bread and
then we'll share the bread now it says
we have machines doing everything so
it's kind of like I don't know know you
I don't care you provide nothing for me
you're a threat to my life and thus we
disconnect from each other and then you
see this the same thing that makes a man
sit there and just film and other men be
killed is the same thing that makes that
man kill that other man there is just no
connection I think that the the one of
the things that's not that you guys
haven't mentioned is the fact that if
anyone does help and they they hurt the
guy that's got the gun they're gonna go
to jail yeah the state's going to
prosecute yeah why should there's no
incentive to intervene yeah like
Universe incentive everyone knows that
like I'm a gun guy right I'm a very Pro
2A guy like I've got opinions that are
as Extreme as Tim or more extreme
um I carry a gun all the time like
everyone knows it if I'm in a place
where you know I'm not supposed to have
a gun and I happen to have a gun I'm not
doing anything I'm not helping anyone if
I'm in a place where I can have a gun
and I know that that it's an unfriendly
District like in A D like a DA would
prosecute me for for intervening I'm not
helping but not only that even if you're
in a place with constitutional carry you
run the risk of civil liability
absolutely you'll get sued in some other
state or who knows what absolutely I
remember years ago watching videos out
of China where this same kind of thing
happened where somebody would get run
over or someone get attacked and nobody
did anything because the same thing
happens that we're talking about is they
just say I don't want to intervene
because the liability is too high and
that's we're still just uh on the
getting run over thing I heard that they
will kill you if they hit you in the car
the liability is more if you survive
than if you die if they kill you they go
to jail for a few years if they
permanently injure you they're they got
to pay pay for your life for the rest of
their lives so what they'll do is
they'll get out look at the person and
just run them over finish them off the
level of apathy that we're seeing in our
society is very disheartening it's not
just apathy it's actively avoiding
situations that put you in the
crosshairs of the government do you
think this is the negative side effect
of the Live and Let Live mentality no if
you're watching this you're like I know
something bad's gonna happen but I I
don't know what the context is I
shouldn't intervene there might be
something like do we think that we have
bred a culture that feels like they are
supposed to stay out of everything I
think maybe maybe but I think that it's
when it comes to violence that we've
significantly disincentivized people
from acting on behalf of their fellow
humans because the government or the
government will allow people that are
risking their lives to save other people
the government will allow those people's
lives to be ruined look at Kyle
Rittenhouse
right like you don't even if you don't
like the situation with Kyle and think
he shouldn't have been there Etc that
doesn't matter the D.A went after him
and they're still going after him yeah
they're they're trying to go after him
the kid that literally had a gun out and
that he shot in the arm that survived
who said he wanted to kill Kyle
Rittenhouse who said I wish I unloaded
in him told his buddy there and that
they're allowing reportedly yeah
reportedly they're allowing that kid to
still bring a civil suit well the risk
to reward ratio isn't even worth it like
you said somebody intervenes and they
think to themselves well if I put my
life on if I risk my life and I do help
this guy and he does survive or and he
does get prosecuted what he's going to
go to jail for a year he's not you're
not taking a murder off the street for
his entire life you might get him off
the street for a little bit so the
reward isn't there for people and in St
Louis was at the end of January this
year there was a 17 year old who pled
guilty to shooting at a police officer
and he wasn't even given jail time he
was given less than a year of the social
work program so I mean the laws just
aren't in favor of the law-abiding
citizen it's empowering criminals
because they know that they're not going
to get prosecuted for for murder just
about remember the mccloskeys no tell me
about them the mccloskeys live in St
Louis and a bunch of black lives matter
Riders broke the fence to their private
Community walked in and the mccloskeys
came out with guns on their own property
and said back off get away and the
mccloskeys got arrested had their guns
confiscated and then ended up having to
cut some deal or something I think the
governor stepped in on their behalf and
pardoned him or or something and said
you know you decided that they weren't
Prosecuting but the D.A wanted to
prosecute which is ex and now inside in
St Louis this is where this guy gets
killed so the D.A
prosecuted or tried to prosecute them
kloskeys and then
demonstrated you are not in a position
to defend yourself or anyone else
because ideology and now now you have
this example of what happens obviously
one is not led to the other directly but
when you have a
the notion that you cannot defend
yourself or others you don't get people
helping out the mccloskeys got charged
with two felony counts of unlawful in
lawful use of a weapon weapon and
tampering with evidence for having guns
on their own property it's ridiculous I
mean every it's just ridiculous when you
have law-abiding citizens who feel
fearful for protecting themselves and it
really does empower criminals and it
makes me think about the Michigan State
University student because I went to
Michigan State University I graduated
last year I saw friends there I have
loved ones there I have family that goes
there and that's a gun-free zone and so
again that's another example of
empowering the criminals while
law-abiding citizens do not have the uh
I guess just the resources or the you
know feel the ability to protect
themselves I'm a concealed pistol
license holder in the state of Michigan
and I carried almost everywhere I went
the one place I never carried was on
campus when I went to school there and
so when I think about that and I think
about me graduating last year
if I didn't have I wouldn't have had a
gun on campus I couldn't have protected
myself or others if I was in that
situation I'm thankful I wasn't but the
fact is there are three students at MSU
that aren't alive that should have been
um you know would that have would the
gun free zone save those people I don't
know but again it's about inching away
and taking away step by step our rights
um and and the feeling of our ability to
to protect ourselves and does the
gun-free zone make them targets right if
I wanted to do something wrong and
wanted a place to do it I would go to
the place where I knew people weren't
armed right right if you're already
going to commit a crime you don't care
if you're violating uh the gun-free zone
right and I moved to Texas after I
graduated and I'll say that I carried
every day there it's an open carry state
and I've never felt safer I saw people
with guns on their hips all the time and
I it was a very nice feeling to be quite
honest yeah
cultural decay
I don't know man I think your point
about the size of community is worth
noting uh Andrew Heaton who does the
political orphanage podcast he had an
episode that was recently saying what's
the optimum size of community because at
a certain point you just don't know
people and therefore you're unable 300
or is it like 3 million because like
whatever but that is very difficult to
govern right like if you had 300 people
well you made a whole bunch of if we had
uh I don't even know how many it would
be in America but hundred thousands of
300 people community that would be very
difficult to regulate or to coordinate
efforts across the state the issue is
not so much the size of community it is
to a certain degree it's a lack of
culture it's a lack of morals right so
you can have 20 billion people and if
each and every one of those people
believed that if they did wrong they
would burn for eternity then they might
not do wrong however we've got it we've
got people of all different views and
all different faiths who do not agree
and some in fact believe believe they
are obligated to strike down blasphemers
and apostates in which case you get more
because of that that Faith system I
think that if people in this country all
had an agreement on say like the Golden
Rule then you wouldn't have to you
wouldn't even need police officers you
wouldn't need police with a billion
people if everyone agreed on the
morality but they don't and some people
are predators who want to exploit and
harm other people and so now you've got
stuff like this and I guess you combine
the a growing civilization more and more
people
with the fact that our culture is
fragmented and breaking apart and
digital media is creating decentralized
networks and tribes
it's gonna get worse right so we used to
have with just the five big TV networks
everybody believed the same things but
now with the internet some people watch
show like this some people watch other
shows what you're gonna end up with is
small pockets of different tribes who
are just untrusting of other groups and
then you get stuff like this man yeah I
mean but at the end of the day we are
you know we're human beings and we do
have instincts to want to be around
people that think like us that look like
us even
um and that's why you have when you have
homogeneous societies they are very high
trust societies look at Japan I mean
it's very homogeneous everyone looks the
same talks the same has the same culture
and here in America we have every
ethnicity we have every religion we have
every type of culture and as human
beings that have that you know
instinctual need for community and for
people that share the same values and
morals that becomes difficult when you
cram everybody into one city and say you
know do your thing like good luck and
that's why I even see this guy that's
been going viral on Twitter recently
this black guy in New York like he's
yelling oh yeah minority like he's
terrorizing the city
um and just yelling at him so I do think
it comes down to Shared values shared
religion you know shared morals thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time